Thanks thanks to all of you for coming
so I'm going to talk about this paper
please feel free to just interrupt me
ask questions as we go along that's how
we tend to do things and I get nervous
if nobody's asking any questions this is
joint work with Jesse Shapiro who's an
economist at Brown and Matt tatty who is
a statistician at microsoft research and
Chicago Booth and this paper is part of
a broader agenda I guess that we have
trying to measure and understand
political polarization in the US and the
particular thing that we're thinking
about in this project is partisan speech
and partisan language so anybody who's
been paying attention knows there are
people on the right foot on the left in
this country talk very differently this
slide is now totally out of date because
we've replaced this with hundreds and
one new partisan phrases radical Islamic
terrorism so on and so forth but you
know over the period of data that we're
going to be looking at which goes back a
long way there are lots of different
examples estate tax and death tax you
know Republicans when they're talking
about taxes like to talk about tax
relief because that sounds like
relieving some terrible burden from you
Democrats like to talk about tax break
to describe those same policies because
that sounds like somebody's getting out
of something that they should pay it was
noted after the shooting in orlando at
that nightclub that within a couple of
days the left and right had coalesced
into people on the Left calling that
event a mass shooting people on the
right calling that event a terrorist
attack those two things plugging in two
very different narratives so we've been
interested in partisan language for a
while it's clear today if you look at
this that at least a lot of this
language does not arise by accident but
that there's a whole sort of industry of
focus groups and consultants and people
who are trying to think about how to
make rhetoric as effective as possible
so these are memos written by frank
luntz who's one of
most famous such consultants these are
memos that were distributed to
Republican congressional candidates and
they're sort of manuals of how should
you talk what words should you use to
talk about taxes what words should use
to talk about health care you want to
call it Obamacare a Washington takeover
of health care for example another
example from those memos she was back in
two thousand six at the time that George
W Bush was proposing reforming Social
Security and there was a big debate
about reforming Social Security once
says when if you're Republican talking
about that don't call that privatization
of Social Security which is what
basically everybody had called it up
until then because privatization makes
people nervous makes them scared they
think of Russia and Eastern Europe and
all kinds of bad things instead say what
we're trying to do is personalized
Social Security we want to talk about
the personalization of Social Security
people like that better in his focus
groups now that might sound like a good
idea it might sound crazy
personalization is not a such an easy
word to trip off your tongue but what is
clear if you look at the data is that
people in Congress follow this advice so
if you look at the 2005 Congress
Republicans say personal account 184 x
in private account only five times
Democrats wildly reversed the other way
I'm not sure quite what happened to the
five Republicans who screwed up and said
private account but pretty much
everybody is getting the memo and
following along and what's also true
from we know this from our past work
from other people's work is this kind of
partisan language doesn't just stay in
Congress it's not some idiosyncratic
thing that's restricted to debate in
Congress but it filters out through the
media and into the way we all talk about
politics so just as an example these are
headlines from the Washington Post in
the Washington Times centre-left way on
the right newspapers respectively a
given event the washington post is using
private accounts the washington times of
using personal account
in DC no we don't know what actual
diffusion yeah so I think there's like a
separate really interesting set of
questions that we're not going to tackle
hear that people other people have
thought about some but I think there's a
lot more work to do understanding how do
these things get born diffuse we know
for for many of the individual cases to
like death tax for example which is
quite a famous example of this as a
thing to call the tax that you pay on
your state after you die you know that
word if you trace it back actually goes
way back so people are using that phrase
going all the way back like in the 19th
century but very rarely and then there's
a specific moment where one of these
basically one of these consultants
popularized is using a ten it kind of
takes off but i think there's there's a
bunch of interesting questions i think
it partly that this research will
suggest i talked to you editing before
and was saying to one of your students
today I something I would love to do is
look at like with that example of the
Orlando nightclub shooting when things
happen and these kinds of political
framings evolve very quickly in real
time kind of you over that short time
span you know in the in the minutes
hours days after something happens how
long does it take us to figure out this
is the way we should frame it but that's
not going to be there this paper this
paper is going to ask what in a sense is
a very simple question and one to be
honest we sort of thought of as like
okay well we'll do this to start you
know in the first month and then move on
to all the other questions and that one
question ended up being I won't tell you
how many years that we've been working
on this we just want to know is this a
new phenomenon to what extent is the
partisan division in language that we
see today something which has always
been true is it something which has it
might be true in the past just using
different words is it something that's
evolved over time maybe it was high in
the past than low than high or some kind
of genuinely new innovation and so what
we're going to do is
we have we had the complete text of the
US Congressional Record going back to
1873 based on OCR text so that's like a
verbatim transcript of everything that
was said in Congress over that period
you know each of those years is like a
few thousand pages like bound volumes in
a library and so we're going to try to
measure trends and partisanship over
that period there is at least for us may
not seem like a methodological challenge
to you guys but we started out basically
approaching this using what seemed to us
like an obvious statistical methodology
which we then subsequently discovered as
I'll show you goes way wrong and so
there's a basic challenge here in
getting good estimates of this change in
partisanship over time that account for
the fact that the quality of the data is
changing the amount of speech is
changing a lot of other things are
changing over time and we want to try to
try to decompose those so there's the
paper has in part a methodological piece
what we're going to show you a couple of
measures but the main one that we
ultimately focus on is sort of a simple
choice model using some method borrowed
for machine learning and text analysis
to try to address that issue and so
we'll look at what is the overall trend
them and we'll try to break that out and
decompose what's going on just just as
background you know there is some prior
work there's prior work on polarization
in Congress there's prior work on
polarization in the public there's also
some prior work on language but the
takeaway from this literature broadly
and this is part of why this ended up
being interesting to us is it mostly has
the thrust of the idea we all have that
polarization is going way up or that
what's happening today is somehow
unprecedented is basically a myth like
if you look at the data you don't see
that so so the literature looking at
voters that's been argued very strongly
mo fury know who's a political scientist
here at Stanford and others have argued
basically the idea that the American
public is getting more polarized is
amiss
looking at Congress we do see it going
up recently so the typical measure is
something like looking at how people
vote in Congress looking at roll call
votes those do show increasing
polarization over time but they also
show that polarization was as high or
higher in the past earlier in this
century or earlier in the last century
the late 19th century so that all has a
flavor of nothing is really new so
you'll see that what we find here is a
little bit different than that okay and
then just a flag there's there's one
paper by Suresh Naidu who's an MS any
here and some co-authors that that
looked at a very similar question using
basically the same data and so we're
going to end up differing from them
mainly in like the methodology and the
answer that we ultimately get so I'll
tell you about that okay so this is as
we said Congressional Record text it's
like raw OCR text so there's some work
to do to turn that into structured data
where we can identify when a speech
stops and ends who is the speaker for a
given speech and then matching that to
metadata about the speakers like their
party that we're going to need to use we
do some standard kind of text processing
stuff and we're going to end up for the
purpose of this project the main results
i'm going to show you are all treating
this as counts of by grams basically so
we're going to have two word phrase yeah
so these are so we are removing stems
taking out a bunch of stop words and so
we're combining these yeah yeah so
that's what we're using the porter
Center which is like a standard
feminization and so we end up with
counts of these friends desire something
that's important background as we start
looking at these results and you'll see
why it matters is just that the total
amount that people talk in Congress has
gone way up over time so this is just
like the total amount of speech in
Congress from 1882 the present and it's
gone very sharply up we looked into this
because we were puzzled like why is it
so dramatic over this period in the
1960s but it turns it's not a mistake in
the data it really is
number of bills being introduced the
amount that Congress is in session the
amount that a given person talks all
these things are going up over time
that's going to be important once I
start talking about potential bias in
some of these naive estimators that you
might use because as I'll show you this
there's this important small sample bias
how big that is is going to depend on
how small the sample is so it's going to
be bigger back here and smaller up here
okay we then talked about how we
approach this problem from from a
modeling perspective we're going to
we're going to think of basically a
simple statistical model without a lot
of detailed underlying modeling of what
are the objectives of the people doing
this speech so following a lot of
literature and in text mining we're
going to think of the vector of by gram
counts that we observe as a result of a
multinomial process so what we see for
each person each congress member in each
year is a vector of counts the dimension
of that vector is the total size of the
vocabulary so there's one entry for each
possible phrase that could have been
said that's like on the order of a
million and we're going to assume that
each person has a party affiliation
which is either Republican or Democrat
we throw out the small number of people
who have third party or independent
affiliation importantly we're going to
want to control for a vector of
observables in doing this that's going
to include things like region
interacting with time so one of the big
things that changes in Congress over
this period is the realignment of the
south going from being overwhelming
Democratic to Republican you could
imagine how that could screw up what
we're doing here if for example the
suddenly all of the Democrats all of the
Democrats used to use sort of southern
language that's going to look like a
partisan difference in language but it's
really a regional difference in language
and we want to separate regional
differences from party differences so
we'll think of those vectors as drawn
from a multinomial where there's some
the back
sure of probabilities in that
distribution the true probabilities of
you trays they're going to vary over
time they're going to depend on your
party that's the key thing we're going
to be interested in and they're going to
depend on this vector of control and so
once once if we take this leap notice
that this is it seems kind of totally
standard if you're in some you know
statistics audience or doing doing text
mining but if you actually thought of
this as a model of language it's totally
crazy the idea that the way I'm talking
is taking it may sound to you like this
is what I'm doing but taking repeated
iid drawers where each word that I say
is independent of the last word I say at
the very strange model of language avi
ignores a lot of dependents across words
once we take this leap though we can
define the question that we want to ask
how partisan is language in a much more
precise way which is basically going to
boil down to how different are those two
vectors of choice probabilities that's
what we will mean here by partisanship
how different is the speech of Democrats
and Republicans and how has that changed
over time Paul is that way you could
think of a lots of different metrics you
could put on how different are those two
cube actors good look at Euclidean
distance between them you could use
segregation measures which are a natural
kind of metric for this sort of thing
what we're going to do is slightly
different we're going to use a measure
that we think then gives some nice
interpretation which is just what is the
diagnostician of language about party
that is in a given year how well can I
guess your party from hearing you speak
for a fixed amount of time so if hearing
somebody talk for a minute in two
thousand i can guess their party much
better than I could have in nineteen
fifty you will say that partisanship of
language has gone up but the language is
more different between the two parties
yes the two parties spoke about an issue
but we also see another effect where
different party speak about different
issues right where if you hear me
talking about college
learn something that I'm probably in
slept week I'm wondering are there ways
to actually the singer's news in the way
that you can Alton it doesn't seem like
there would be not yet not at this stage
so so this this model and then posing
the question our answer is going to be a
combination of those two things it's
going to combine so our measure could be
high either because you use different
language to talk about the same thing or
you talk about different things
Democrats talk about poverty Republicans
talk about terrorism or something like
that at the end I'll come back to that
and show you what we have done to try to
decompose those which is you know
imperfect but I think we have a good
first step of trying to do that but
that's a very good question okay
remember you can get you out as well and
if you want okay so let me just show you
what this means formally then what what
exactly is our measure so thinking like
a bayesian world here imagine you're a
bayesian observer there's some
politician in front of you you don't
know who they are you have a 50-50 prior
on whether they were a Republican or a
Democrat and you hear them say one
phrase in this world of the model you
hear them say one phrase and that turned
out to be phrased J what is the
posterior probability you place on that
person being a Republican it's going to
be this the probability that a
Republican would have said that phrase
over the total probability that that
phrase would have been said we're going
to call that road JT so you can think of
that as a as a measure of the Republican
appraise phrase is more Republican of
hearing somebody say it tells you
they're a Republican then ex ante what
is the posterior that I expect to assign
to your true party that is how well in
this sense do I think I'll be able to
guess your true party that's going to be
given by this expression so remember we
said you were equally likely to be a
Republican or a Democrat if you happen
to be a Republican which happens with
probability point five which phrase you
say will be determined by Q and
for each of those phrases I will assign
posterior row so the expectation will
grow over the phrases you might say is
given by that product and same thing for
Democrats but now my posterior on your
true party is 1 minus Rho so this is
roughly speaking this is the probability
I expect to be able to guess your true
party and that's going to be our main
measure the only other wrinkle is this
depends on X and we want one measure
that there'll be one number for a given
year so our main measure is going to be
the average of that across the exes that
occur in a given session so it's going
to be saying what if I had two
politicians that i had to guess and they
had in some sense average
characteristics what's the chance I
could tell them apart so that's our main
measure of partisanship you see it goes
from one half to one so if it's one half
I'll never be able to guess your party
from how you speak if it's one that
means that the vocabularies are totally
non overlapping so there's like a set of
language that Republicans used in a set
of language Democrats because there's no
overlap so if I hear you say one thing I
could tell for sure you train this every
year we're actually we're going to fit
that it we're going to finish the entire
series and they're just a the only thing
that makes that different from just
separately sitting at every year is the
coefficients on these X's are going to
be the same across your small few
observations of the phrase in a given
year I physically when you're doing
technologies you just drop everything
with fewer and K occurrences exactly
what I looking would be different if I'm
training for years and now I'm losing a
lot more in detail yeah vs the final
packaging it yeah let me show you
so we're going to talk about fastest
what are we doing for ages that's going
to be at the heart of this bias that can
screw us and other people but yeah you
should think of it as the case where
we're doing a sesame kept buying years
therefore we need a lot of information
and we would be losing I'll show you
that if we make that K reasonably high
we start to lose a lot of information
okay okay so this is this is like a
simple model and it's a simple
statistical problem basically if we
wrote down that model how would we
estimate what're we need to estimate
what these cues are and then once we
know what the cues are we can plug them
in and compute this measure so the
question is how would we estimate this
pie how do we estimate those cues so
here's here's where we get back to the
sort of narrative of this project what
did we initially do the the sort of
obvious thing to do if your sugar coming
at this from econometrics kind of
statistics we grew up on is you say well
look these cues or something that have
an analog in the data that's what share
of the time that this phrase is said is
it said by a Republican so a natural
estimator for Q is just a share of the
actual times that phrase was said in a
particular year my point that were said
by Republicans once you know have that
estimator you can plug that in to
estimate row and you can plug it in to
estimate the whole thing this is the
maximum likelihood estimator for this
model it's not crazy it inherits all of
the nice properties of maximum
likelihood efficiency consistency but
the key thing is those asymptotics are
right as you know emily is good
asymptotically in general when n gets
big right that's what the theorems and
statistics say what is n here n getting
big here means that the amount of speech
you have / phrase has to get big because
each of these cues has to converge to
the truth so that the overall thing
converges to the truth and so the
problem is going to be were miles from
that because we have lots and lots and
lots of phrases that are very rare and
and that's going to make this and also I
mean this might seem so simple as to be
kind of dumb but there are a bunch of
other things that people have done that
you would be natural applications of
sort of simple text mining methods to
this that are going to suffer from the
same problem but suppose you forget that
didn't hadn't thought about that
potential bias and you just said well
let's go ahead and estimate this this is
what you would have gotten so this is
partisanship of speech over time based
on that Emily estimate and we weren't
doing exactly this but a grass something
like this it's what we first computed
and we spent I won't tell you how much
time staring at it thinking how
interesting it was you know actually
speech was much more partisan in the
past than it is today and then at some
point as a kind of cross-check
diagnostic it occurred to us to do the
following thing let's just take our data
randomly reshuffle who in the data is a
Republican and a Democrat like reshuffle
the party labels and recompute the model
that kind of permutation test is like a
standard diagnostic to make sure you're
not screwing up and in this context we
know that if we randomly assign the
party labels we know what the truth
should be partisanship should be 0 point
5 you can't tell how somebody's party
from their speech if we randomly
assigned the labels independently of
your speech so we let's do that let's
computer let's make sure it's a flat
line at point five and when you do that
you get this so this is the same
partisanship estimated on the data where
we randomly assign party labels so that
was not so good for us what does it mean
it means by definition that there is a
big bias in these estimators right even
on data where the truth is point five
were estimating point six and that bias
is bearing a lot over time what is that
coming from how do you think about that
it's actually quite simple if I have
data where many many phrases are only
said three or five or seven times
they're going to be lots of phrases that
look partisan by chance just happen that
the Republicans said at five times and
the Democrats never said it and the
model that I wrote down if we estimate
it using that plug-in estimator is going
to attribute all of that to being true
partisanship if it was said five times
by Republicans my best guess is wow this
is a phrase that only Republicans say
right yes so good darling why that long
exactly yeah that this we're treating me
plugged it in we're then going to treat
your visas if it was estimated correctly
and so we're giving a lot of weight to
that long tail and so it's intuitive
that the bias is upward right because
imagine the case where the true queues
are actually the same then the sample qs
can only be more different than that
it's going to be biased or being
different and it's intuitive that it
might fit what matters for this time
series is the size of that bias is
varying over time what would it tend to
vary with obviously is going to vary
with the amount of speech we have and I
showed you there's much less speech
early on than later so that's going to
tend to produce this trend okay let me
not belabor the this too much so you can
write out a kind of decomposition of
where this bias is coming from and
understand it we can actually show that
the first order approximation of that
bias if you just if you only account for
the fact that the amount of speech is
changing you actually get a pattern and
the bias it looks very similar to this
meaning it really is just the change in
total speech to this driving a lot of it
so that ends up being the problem we
need to solve this just for comparison
is the plot from that published paper by
Jensen at all that I mentioned and so
their big conclusion in this paper so
the pink line is is the series from
their published paper their big
conclusion is you know polarization has
been going up but are also used to be
the same in the past this happens to
look very similar to the time pattern of
polarization estimated based on roll
call votes and so they're sort of saying
you know poehler's polarization in
speech looks like polarization and other
things the dotted line here is is
randomly assigned parties using their
data and you see that the first half of
that the fact that it is high in the
past seems to be an artifact of this
kind of pious so that shows up in their
measure too ok so what you said an
obvious thing to do if this is your
problem is just let's cut then the
number of phrases to get rid of the ones
that are used rarely and the trade-off
in that is going to be that is going to
tend to reduce the bias but it's also
going to reduce the signal in the data
and leave you with a lot of annoying so
it this is just showing you as you as
you cut more and more aggressively this
is like we only keep phrases spoken at
least 500 times you do diminish the bias
so that gray line is getting flatter and
flatter but you also end up with quite a
lot of noise and so this you see even
the grey line here is going up and down
quite a lot over time so the uncertainty
of what's happening over this period
you're left with is pretty high or here
too you see these kind of pop ups and
downs that are also there in the random
Syria so they're there to other things
to do that we think are better than that
we're going to kind of introduce two
possible solutions that have different
pros and cons so one is what we'll call
a leave out estimator not going to go
through the details of this but
basically one way to think about the
source of the bias is this product in
our mejor q which is how often something
was said times Rho which is how
Republican was that phrase in the in the
basic measure those two things are
estimated using the same data and this
is a monotonically increasing function
of that and that means the sample
covariance between those two things is
going to be positive because they have
the same errors in them their varying
together so the approach of this measure
is to say let's essentially use
different data to estimate the cues and
activate the rows to make those
independent by construction and that is
similar to dropping data it's going to
get rid of the bias but it's going to
throw out a lot of information as well
this is this is what you get if you do
that so this starts the gray line is now
flat at point five starts to look like
something closer to two what we end up
thinking is the right answer and it
starts to look like something really has
changed
recently our preferred estimator is
going to be somewhat different from that
we're going to estimate that multinomial
model but we're going to use similar
sort of penalized estimation lasso type
penalties if you're familiar with that
to control over fitting and we'll do it
in a particular way we'll use some
tricks approximating that multinomial
likelihood with a plethora it's going to
take account of the fact that we know
which phrases were set a lot in which
were said few and so those cues for
phrases that were only set a couple of
times are going to be pulled back close
to equal but it's going to let the ones
we have a lot of data for speak clearly
coefficients that are small like 20
right essentially trying to say you only
care about these thing and in practice
wouldn't that have there's some more
best to dropping the raisin sudden you
don't see very much to those in there
the island doesn't anyway whether it is
going to do mr. 70 people in your
project which is similar definitely is
equivalent to drop in the only
difference is we're choosing this latest
drop not just based on frequency of
occurrence but also based on how
asymmetrically there says right by the
tomorrow right and so that point and
it's all I mean there's like a little
wrinkle because of these axes that are
controlled it's also going to be using
you know choosing them based on the
marginal information that phrase
relative to those control variables but
it's it is in the same spirit I think
any model you estimate using these data
is going to have to do some kind of
feature selection and so this is just
going to do it in a in a in a better way
from the perspective of trading off by
into bias and variance perhaps than just
dropping based on number of occurrence
correctly okay this is the final series
that we estimate that we've squeezed out
a lot of the noise you can see the gray
series is not flat point 5 and this
paints qualitatively a very different
pic
than any of the ones that i showed you
before he says unlike roll call votes
unlike all of these measures of what's
going on with voters if we look at the
way people talk in Congress something
really is different today than at any
point in the past going all the way back
to 1880 and interestingly that change
happens very sharply and discreetly in
the early 1990s so we'll tie it's all
MTV absolutely it's me graduating from
high school that's the thing that drove
polarization in the u.s. so we'll talk
about thoughts on what happened there
let me show you some other results to
kind of start to unpack this and I'll
skip over some of these quickly to make
sure we have time to discuss so one
thing you could ask about this it's like
okay went way up but is the magnitude of
this important you know by our measure
something something I that I made up
went from you know point 50 to 2.5 25 is
that big is that small who knows
remember that the unit here are what is
the probability I could guess your true
party if I hear one phrase that's what
these units mean and so as a way to
think about the magnitudes we can use
the fitted model to translate that into
the equivalent answer for any number of
phrases so this is on the x-axis how
many phrases do I get to hear on the
y-axis what's the chance I could guess
your party the more I get to hear the
better I could guess your party and this
is showing that in 1873 1989 and 2008
and you can see that it again really
didn't change between those two years by
the end of our data and about two
thousand eight if I hear you speak for
one minute I can guess your party with
about eighty percent probability whereas
before that was 53 4 houses have
machinery so is this a present for you
saying that I'm sampling the bunch of
different races that are non-overlapping
is this I have some
that like actual test yeah this is wrong
the fitted model imagine it's like I fit
the parameters of that multinomial model
and now we're going to do it in
simulated data from the mall so we're
going to simulate the model says now we
have an estimate of the correct
probability distribution across the
phrases so I'm going to say well
simulate a bunch of data from
Republicans simulate a bunch of data
from Democrats and compare and we don't
actually do the simulation because in
this case there's like some actually I
think we do I take that back we now we
switch to doing the simulation because
it to make it correct so we actually do
it well I mean yeah estimate only the
only information that the estimates use
is the frequency with which people say
the phrase is we want to do it using the
estimates rather than the raw data
precisely because we want to be doing
that waiting of things that were said a
lot relative to things that were said a
little um but I think I think a fair
question is could we do versions of
something similar as maybe it's like a
cross-check on this using like a
cross-validation type approach on a
holdout sample and I think the answer is
yes we could do more of that ok so I'm
going to here is just a curious are
matters of speech and the traditional
iron measure of partisanship of roll
call votes the polarization ideological
polarization in Congress we started out
expecting basically what we would
estimate would sort of track this more
or less and clearly it doesn't so very
importantly here this says we are not
arguing the speech is a measure of the
degree of polarization and some broad
sense you might think this is a measure
of the degree of polarization in some
broad sense what's clear is the process
that drives partisan language is
different from
and it's really operating some
independent track here that's just the
cross section of that which I'll skip so
now we have this fitted model we have it
fit on 130 years of data I'd like to dig
in and look at more what's going on
including within and between topics so
let me show you a bit of that so one
thing you'd like to look at from the
fitted model is well which are the most
part is in phrases what are the phrases
that are really diagnostic in a given
year how is that changing over time this
measure gives us a nice way to define
what is a partisan phrase in this model
which is if you took that if you took a
given phrase out of the vocabulary how
much would my predictive power fall so
if I prohibited people from using the
phrase radical Islamic terrorism how
would my chance of guessing who's a
Republican go down so once we do that we
can define for any given year kind of at
random here's 1907 to 1908 what are the
most partisan Republican phrases and the
most partisan Democratic phrases you
could stare at this for a while
depending on your knowledge of US
history it might make sense it might
make not so much sense I had no idea
what these things were if you go look a
good cross check its to go look at the
party platforms in this year kind of
figure out what's going on so this is
very consistent the Republican platform
in that year the main thing that it was
calling for was taking care of veterans
of the Spanish American Indian Wars and
a bunch of these phrases are about that
Democrats were in sort of trust-busting
mode trying to attack big corporations
and these phrases are related to those
things Bureau of corporations is like
the predecessor of the FCC antitrust
enforcement for the US so you could do
this for a bunch of yours note to the
earlier question these are really
differences in topics rather than
different language for the same thing
this is that the Republicans are talking
about wars and the Democrats are talking
about antitrust basically I won't go
through the in detail you can see
similar things in other years fast
forward to 1995 which is the year the
first Congress where this thing really
starts shoe
up and the picture you see is pretty
different for example there's a bunch of
phrases on both sides related to taxes
republicanism tax relief Democrats are
saying tax breaks tax breaks for the
wealthy the wealthiest debt pack and
estate tax or on the list a little
further down so here it looks more like
starting to use different language to
talk about a given topic it's just a
distribution which all together one
thing you might have wondered is how
much is it change is new phrases being
introduced new coinages like that fax
maybe so the way we and this is sort of
related to where do these things come
from although not it doesn't really get
out too much so the simple thing that we
did is say let's separate out all
vocabulary that first appears in
Congress post-1980 versus vocabulary
that had always existed and just compute
the partisanship of those two subsets of
taxes separately so what does that mean
it means imagine i'm doing my guess your
party exercise but you're only allowed
to use the historical vocabulary or I'm
doing my gesture party exercise and
you're only allowed to use post-1980
vocabulary so this is the partisanship
just using the post-1980 vocabulary
which is much much much higher
suggesting that what is new is very
partisan but you almost can't see it on
this graph because it's so much lower
but if I just use the old vocabulary
it's still going up and up almost as
much as the baseline measure so the old
vocabulary is getting more partisan as
well okay so let's talk about topics
then we would like a clean way to divide
changes in what you talk about from
changes and how you talk about it doing
that requires some definition of what
are topics and we played around with a
bunch of different ways of doing that in
the end what we settled on was a fairly
we try we did various automated things
we ended up settling on a fairly manual
pro
to try to get topics that were a fairly
small set of topics that had clear
semantic interpretation so we basically
do an iterated thing where we look at
the most partisan phrases kind of divide
those into what seemed like the most
important topics use those to define
keywords look at the phrases that come
back use those to define some more
keywords and kind of keep iterating
until we get set the phrases associated
with each topic so these are not saying
that these are okay so so we started we
were looking at the most partisan phrase
lists as as a way to identify the main
topics but we were these are not
necessarily the most partisan topics in
the sense that like once we realize
they're a bunch of partisan phrases
having to do with mail and we take
everything it has to do with mail
whether it's part of their not but yes
the postal service was in the past a
very partisan issue so here's that
decomposition the pink series as usual
is our main measure the Black Series is
within topic partisanship so what does
that mean it means I have to guess your
party but only you're only allowed to
use one topic and between topic
partisanship is I have to get your party
but all i get to see is which topic
you're choosing not the actual words you
used within it does that make sense so
we can define using that break down for
the within we can define partisanship of
each topic individually I only get to
hear you talk about taxes I only get to
hear you talk about defense and this is
just an average of those across topics
so what you see is that most of this
increase is within topics as we've
defined them there is some increase in
the between topic measure here's
something a little bit like the postal
service just to emphasize like not
everything has become more partisan
recently so one of the topics is alcohol
alcohol is not very partisan today when
it's discussed but it used to be very
partisan in the past when during the
Prohibition era and during previous
debates about prohibition in the late
19th century so this is the partisanship
within that topic and this is just the
frequency
with which that topic is discussed here
is defense defense actually was not part
of them very much throughout history
even though it had big spikes where we
would expect around the world wars who
says something being discussed a lot
does not necessarily mean that its
discussion is part of it people talked a
lot about defense around World War two
but you couldn't tell based on how
people were talking who was who because
they were all pretty much on the same
page talking about defense so which
things have gone up a lot these are the
six topics that really drives that
recent increase taxes integration
government health crime and budget
discussions these are these are the
places where we see partisanship going
up a lot and that's going to be a clue
to what happened in the early 1990s to
drive this so let me get to that what
happened in the early nineteen ninety
the cot that the Congress in the data
where the huge change first happened is
not a random Congress it's Congress
following the election in 1994 that was
the year in which Republicans in the US
retook control of Congress for the first
time 50 years or so and it was also an
election famous for the Republican Party
turning a spotlight on language as a
persuasive tool and starting to really
devote a lot of effort to picking and
choosing carefully what words and
phrases we use so this was contract with
america was the platform the republicans
were running under newt gingrich who has
happily come back into our political
life in a prominent way but at the time
was Speaker of the House they won and
frank luntz who I mentioned the
beginning was his pollster basically an
pollster for the Republican Party and so
what they did was use polling techniques
the main the main kind of real
innovation was focused groups where
people respond in real time with like
little dials so somebody will be
speaking about taxes and people are
registering in real time you like what
they're saying you not like what they're
saying may you
that to test different phrases different
vocabulary Franklin says was asked in an
interview do you believe that language
contained a change of paradigm he said I
don't believe it I know what I've seen
it with my own eyes they're washed in
1994 that year when a group of us got
together and said we're going to do
things completely different so there's a
lot of narrative evidence around the
idea that this was a watershed election
in u.s. politics and in particular one
that brought language to center stage as
focus and so that suggests to us the
hypothesis that that what happened that
made language in this country change so
fast it was really some kind of
innovation something that maybe could
have happened 10 years earlier like a
lot of innovations but happened that
this was the year in which people
figured out here is a tool that can be
very effective and started using it and
after the Republican figured it out it
didn't take much time for the Democrats
to copy that and both of them men were
in an arms race who could do this that
we don't have any this paper does not
definitively answer the question of what
happened we don't have any real test of
that one fact sort of consistent with
that hypothesis we can take all of the
phrases that appear in the contract with
america and define those as a topic say
suppose i had just heard somebody use
those phrases what's happening and those
show a very big spike in partisanship
themselves so sir and and if you look at
the topics in the contract with america
they line up very clearly with those
topics i showed you taxes immigration
size of government and so on so it's all
circumstantial evidence but we think
it's circumstantial evidence that points
pretty clearly toward this there are
other things going on and and one of the
other things going on is not exactly MTV
but changes in cable TV and media in
general c-span which is a cable network
that broadcasts everything that's said
on the floor of the House and Senate
live was introduced in the late 70s and
early 1980s this narrative about
Gingrich in the contract with america
there's a lot of people saying this was
played a central role in that because
these guys could get up and talk and
no that what they were saying was going
on TV you should not think that people
watching c-span was an important part of
this story because nobody watches c-span
to a first approximation but what is
true is because of c-span there were all
with TV cameras rolling and if they're
all with TV cameras rolling that means
that anything you say which is kind of
stupid your opponent can use in some TV
commercial the next time anything you
say which is witty and effective you can
use in your TV commercial or it can be
rebroadcast on the nightly news and so
on so you can see this as the way we
would take a bit complementary to this
focus on language and kind of sound
bites the benefit to this innovation
focusing more on what phrase is to say
is higher if once we get really good at
it it's going to be recorded on TV so
you know these things are too early to
be really driving this spike in the 90s
this is just a zooming in on the
previous graph into the contract with
america is really the proximate thing
but these are maybe some complimentary
sort of innovations let me just tell you
my sort of conclusion and then save a
few minutes if people have other
questions to discuss a really fair
question i think at the end of
everything i just showed you is yeah but
who cares like who cares how Congress
people talk to each other in Congress
you know their politicians are a small
number of people they're doing their
weird thing does it matter for anything
and and I have showed you exactly zero
evidence that this matters for anything
and I don't have any evidence directly
it would be great to show here is the
randomized control trial that tells you
the impact of what language is used in
Congress on other things but here's what
we do know as I said there is good
evidence that this kind of language it's
not exactly clear which way the flows
are going all the time but at the end of
the day it is used not only in Congress
but also in the media and also in the
broader public
we know that in laboratory experiments
this kind of language can affect how
people feel about issues their political
beliefs that's the focus groups that
they're using to choose this stuff in
the first place and we know in a much
broader sense that language is an
important driver of group identity and
also of divisions between groups so if
you have two tribes or two groups of
people in Spain or two groups of people
in Canada places where people speak a
different language that for a bunch of
reasons tends to strengthen ties within
groups and deepen divisions between
groups so we don't have evidence where
this but I think speculatively it seems
plausible that the fact that to a much
greater degree in the past that in the
past people on the right and the left in
the country are speaking different
languages that that may be contributing
to this broader kind of divisions that
we see okay I think we have a few
minutes yeah there any other questions
yeah um I love the graphic of separated
by topic were there any compound where
people got my full roster com or not I
mean there's nothing that sort of has
the inverse pattern where it collapses
during the 90s alcohol was one that I
showed you that it was high in the past
and lower today the postal thing is
another actually that has that pattern
but we don't it doesn't there's nothing
that like falls off a cliff in the
nineties I think I think what you see in
the 90s is some things become a lot more
polarized in other statuses do you think
a reverse humane get for dr. just if you
get let's talk about in general go back
to not be yeah I mean again we saw that
in some of those things like like
alcohol I think so we are this close to
having completed this is coming back to
why our papers take five years to write
for a variety of reasons that we wanted
to go back and get we gather the
underlying congressional text here and
in the process also extend the series
further forward so we've been working on
like a new version of this data which
will be much cleaner and which will also
go up to the present so a really good
question is what's going to happen to
that our series stops in 2008 what has
it done since then I think you could
tell very different stories obviously
polarizations gone up a lot on the other
hand you could think about Trump and
Bernie Sanders as somewhat of a backlash
against this kind of very programmed
poll driven focused driven style of
speaking by politicians you know this
the results of this frank luntz thing is
people who do not sound like normal
people normal people don't say
personalization of social security and
so the whole authenticity kind of aspect
of Trump and Sanders you could imagine
is pushing the other way so we'll see
yeah we're let's call it end user
political participation largely
happening in person we're now seeing a
lot more of it happening text drew
things like Twitter Facebook Claus
whatever just there's more reading and
writing habit now than at any time in
recent history and it would be
interesting to see where the
polarization is happening today as well
like it it could be it could be
amplifying it or I'm not actually
certain it's simply agree ways you could
ask that recognizes a well did it
include a skater from different choices
you want to look at this two slightly
different questions one could ask one is
if you pretended that the people on
Twitter were Congress people where do
they fall on this scale like are they
using this language to and the other is
if you have some opera or a way of
categorizing the people on Twitter like
do they follow politicians or their
various ways you could do that how well
can you guess who's who on Twitter
fitting the model separately they're so
allowing those phrases to be different
and then obviously the precisely because
of things having changed so much it's
hard to have long time series they're
going back in time but I think you know
what are the proximate recent trends you
know just the last few years knowing
what the trends look like and in the
partisanship and differences in language
in those forums I think I think would be
really interesting it's less programs
that individuals of those but they use
echo whatever resume yeah yeah it's more
funny part of why I liked you know the
idea of maybe looking at approximate
changes following some events because
that also you don't have time to do a
focus group to say like okay there is a
shooting in orlando how should we talk
about it so those are more organic kind
of changes very similar the previous
question regarding the new genesis
of person language concerns to the
broader public how much of this language
is kind of leaching out or diffusing
into the into our own language so locals
how much and although this is version of
michael question but like how that
evolved once I don't have sure some
about yes erotic co-op is that the ones
who was a little image they do some
looking at the occurrence of the same
language in google books now there's
like nice long time series and so they
find that there is a lot of spillover
into google books that's not
distinguishing which comes first in
which comes second necessarily and then
the stuff here about media we know that
it gets used a lot so so Jesse and I
have another paper where we use we fit a
model on Congress just for a single year
and then we use the occurrence of that
language to measure partisanship of news
outlets to kind of take that as a as a
measure which is like if this news
outlet were a congressperson does it
sound like somebody way on the right or
somebody way on the left and that that
turns out to be a very accurate measure
in the sense that it varies with a lot
of things you would expect it to it and
allows us to then go on and study what
drives those differences across media so
that that language occurs often enough
in the media that you can use it to get
a very accurate read on who should yeah
that that's infected i think the set of
things that we don't yet know and it
would be great i think there's a lot of
interesting work to do with this kind of
data we we we have you know the text of
congress going all the way back there's
also lots of text from media from books
from other sources and so you know more
of this kind of diffusion analysis i
think i think would be great
yeah I'm so yeah lets you have an
interesting hypothesis that or you know
rational vision here which is like part
of the difference not arise organically
it was it was a tactical strategy to use
language in the tool um do we have any
good metrics I mean I could think of
many to sort of understand how effective
that will has been so if you were to
take you know this queue for each you
know or the brig effector on each
politician and then method with you know
cooborating the reelection or something
and try to understand through time like
have people who have used more polarized
language been more successful give any
way to get caught yep so one could run
the kinds of regression i think i would
be skeptical of us because i showed you
you know she's you're here the
correlates of using a lot of this
language or here's how people who use a
lot of this language fair in the
following election that's going to be
mixing up a bunch of other omitted
factors and causality running in the
other direction another thing that makes
it hard talking about the overall
equilibrium impact is this is an
innovation that republicans adopt but
then democrats copy and so you could see
this being some kind of zero-sum game
where like we both adopted this thing
and we're sort of right back where we
started even though if one of us had
adopted and the other hadn't we would
have had a big advantage so the best you
know i wanted to put sites to things
like that on this slide the extent that
we had them and I think the best that I
could come up with was these sort of
laboratory studies that are similar to
the focus groups where they're showing
people different kinds of language
showing different speeches by
politicians varying what words they're
using and looking at people's reported
beliefs but I think in order in order to
do this with naturally occurring data
you really would need some clean source
of variation that you could identify
some kind of natural experiment it would
mean some people are exposed to the
opportunity to do this and other people
aren't and we just haven't been able to
come up with anything like that
yeah yeah great you can let him come up
and Molly enough yeah yeah yeah I know
the chart grab on defense to be quite
interesting how you can kind of talk
about how that spice and certain times
maybe during the world wars and uh you
know like the most current data point so
it going up as well come when for the
topic like you know the fence how could
you I how are you guys you know we know
the you know the parts apart huge our
nation Connie because I feel like
I'm just in terms of you know party or
political parties being a Democrat the
inner proposal yet but I both of them
will be you know talking and you know
about you but this is a bad pic throw a
party once been worse and when he on at
the age of conical overall government
money baby development yeah yeah and
what's behind this graph so the first
step is we have this list of a million
and half phrases that are said in
Congress first step is which of those
shall we say are about defense phrases
and we do this using this kind of
iterated procedure of finding keywords
searching for them finding more keyword
search important so the end of that what
we have is a list of phrases that we're
going to say our defense phrases you
know missile defense attack Russia
whatever stuff that's about defense
we're then going to take the same model
that we have already fit and asked in a
given year if somebody was going to talk
for a minute and they could only talk
about defense how well could I guess
their party and we do that for each year
and and that's what we plot so that
upwards bike means the the way that
these guys are using which phrases
Republicans saying which phrases
Democrats are getting more different in
those years great so I'll hang around in
case people have other questions thank
you all so much this is what
[Applause]